الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا فخلال
ساعات الاخيره شناء طرفها صراع هجمات
متبادله باستعمال سلاح المسيرات واعلن كل
طرف الحاق خسائر بالطرف الاخر وزاره ودفاع
الروسيه اعلنت اسقاط احدى عشره مسيره
اوكرانيه قرب هذه المدينه الاستراتيجيه
تعد مقر اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي كما
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها اسقطت
طائرتين مسيرتين اطلقتا باتجاه موسكو لكن
دون وقوع اصابات في الجهه المقابله اعلنت
السلطات الاوكرانيه ان هجوما شنته القوات
الروسيه بالمسيرات وصواريخ اسكندر استهدف
كلا من مدينتي
كييفولوجيا في محور اخر اعلنت القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه انها افشلت هجوما روسيا
بعشر مسيرات وذلك انطلاقا من شمال شرقي
مقاطعه كورسك الروسيه كما نجحت الدفاعات
الاوكر انيه في اسقاط سبع مسيرات